- [Kelly] Welcome back!
This is in person this time!
- I know we did it via
Zoom kind of the last time.
- I know, it's so weird.
This is what we're like in, in person.
- [Rex] This is amazing.
- Human contact.
- [Rex] I've just been sitting back there.
I could have sat back there
all day and watched you.
- [Kelly] Chilling
'cause you're on Humans.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] And y'all
never met before right?
- [Rex And Margaret Together] No.
- But I'm a huge fan.
- And I love you and we follow each other.
- We do follow each other.
- I love that.
- We all do we're and you
guys are single too, right?
- Well, did you know about our $6 tattoo?
- [Rex] I, I heard.
(audience laughing)
- You have cash?
I take Venmo.
(laughs)
- Take Venmo?
You are so funny.
So wait, on your, on your
new show you're asking
instead of answering the questions.
So how is that?
Was it weird for you?
- Terrifying and I-
- [Kelly] It was weird for me at first.
- I wanna turn that on you because
I, I need some advice.
I still get crazy nervous beforehand.
Interviewing people, you know, you are-
- Now, what do you get nervous about?
- Like, I, I wanna do well for them.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- I don't wanna let them down.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Rex] We all know when somebody comes in
and just kind of mails in an interview.
- [Kelly] They have no idea
what they're talking about
with you yet.
- But I, I wanna, I, you know,
if I'm gonna interview you
I wanna know about you.
So you think that I'm
being, you know, nice.
- [Kelly] Yeah. You do your homework.
- And sincere.
- Absolutely.
- But did it take you a while?
I mean, you're now interviewing
two, three people a day,
but was there a time where
you were super nervous
and do you get over that?
- I, okay, here's the thing,
I didn't really ever get nervous.
Mine was more of like,
I, the thing you said.
I just wanna make sure I'm
doing a good job for them
'cause they're trying
to promote their thing.
And also like I've been that person.
So I didn't wanna like
be the person that asks
about the things that everybody
always asks about with them.
- Right.
- [Kelly] You know what I'm
saying? Like really wanted to
focus on what they're
promoting right then.
But I love connecting.
- [Rex] To converse.
- That's why I think
you love this show and
you love doing it. I love
this show for that reason.
I love connecting with people.
- I do too.
- It's like my favorite thing.
- You know, we've had Ben on.
We had Jason Sudeikis on, recently.
He was great.
So many good people.
Ken Jeong is gonna come on at some point.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, that's
going to be interesting.
- I've already talked to Ken.
- I love him.
- Oh, he's the best.
But again, these are not
people I really know.
I know Ben a little bit.
I knew Jason through basketball.
He's a huge basketball fan.
- Ted Last was funny.
Did you go to set, like on set?
- We went to London.
- That's exciting.
- Went to the bar, where they
supposedly do everything.
I found out they've built
an exact replica of the bar.
- [Kelly] Found out it's all lies.
- It's all lies
- All Lies.
(laughing)
- Jason Sudeikis is a lie.
- [Kelly] Lie! He is a lie!
He is not a happy individual.
I'm just kidding.
No, I love that show. I
just think that's cool
that you got to go like on set.
That's cool.
- It's so amazing, we've gone and
we've interviewed several people.
It's just been, it's been fun.
It's been challenging.
You know, I played
basketball for a long time.
I wouldn't get particularly
nervous about that.
It's something I worked on.
It's, I'm sure,
it's like you guys performing
in front of a crowd.
- Yeah. Like singing, I don't even- yeah.
- You don't. You've worked
on it your whole life.
This is brand new. I've
not done this before.
You know, I've done some
interviews via Zoom,
but sitting down with people
has been pretty daunting.
I love it. It's been fantask- fantastic.
And you know, you can sit
and conversate with people.
It's fun to, and like I'm
starstruck by you guys
at this point. I get
starstruck with anybody I see.
- [Kelly] Yeah, but I
mean, there's a difference.
I think it starstruck, but
there's also excitement.
I still get excited.
Like when you see people that,
I'm a nerd for like shows and like,
things like, so I get excited.
Like people don't think you do,
if you're in the limelight, but I do.
- I get excited that they recognize me
- Yeah.
- Like it's so flattering
too. It's, it's amazing.
- But I think what's special
though, is you make your show.
Everybody thinks that there's, 'cause I-
Whenever I started this show,
I was like, I'm not a journalist.
I'm not a comedian.
I'm like, I just am a
person that loves people.
And I love things and I'm,
I genuinely get excited
about a lot of things.
So like I, I just went
with what I knew, like,
and didn't try and be something else.
And that's what I think you are doing.
And that's why it's successful.
- Thanks.
- Yeah. you've gotta just like, do you.
- You do. And, and I think there's a,
there's a little bit of pressure too.
'Cause I've always said,
there's nothing like being on a team
whether it's in sports or
any other walk of life.
- Yeah.
- And you've got all of these people.
- [Kelly] I would not be able to do this
without my amazing team.
- You wouldn't.
- 100 percent.
- And you don't wanna let them down.
They've all studied this to be
here doing what they've done.
Gone to college, to, to study produc-
to be a producer or
cameraman or whatever it is.
I don't wanna be the weak,
weak link and let everybody else down.
- Oh, that's such a
sports ball thing to say.
(crowd laughing and clapping)
- Yeah. Only as strong
as our weakest link.
- That's right.